the playoffs all is fair in competition
you know so if some somebody's going to
call me out in my name i'm going to look
at them straight in the eye and see if
they really bout it
most of the time they're not do you feel
like the hostility you get
there's no hostility bro it's basketball
when you were flicking some people off
i'd say that's some hostility are you
guessing that that's hostility or like
we've never seen that from you this
season where you are running down the
floor or flicking people off
it's the first time you actually caught
it because it's a big time game i
respond in different ways you know i'm
saying i'm not trying to focus on that
if you want to ask me questions about
the fans go ask them go on the street
and ask them questions right do you feel
like the energy you get from fans in
this building embrace it best
from you embrace it embrace it it's the
dark side embrace it
are we going to spend time talking about
uh if you want to fans and yelling at
players and players reacting to the face
it's part of the game
okay without question i grew up in texas
as part of the game i went to school
down south ncc louisiana played for the
lakers and magic it's part of the game
and the best thing you could do is one
stay a consummate professional
and send their ass home within the
series that's i mean that's the best
thing you can do
again what does remaining a consummate
professional in the moment mean to you
listen
i had a conversation with bill russell
and he told me some things that i never
knew and the things that they had to go
through if he persevered and to become
one of the greatest big man that's the
type of action i want that's the type of
professional i want to be muhammad ali
karim you know jackie robinson all
all the people who made it uh you know
made it pave the way for us to be up
here now they stayed professional and
you know they had to go through some
real stuff does that mean you don't
react i don't know yeah i react by
whoever on the court bus in their ass
and send them home
that's how you're right you don't get
you know you don't listen you don't cry
and whine about it especially let me
tell you some boston philly new york
they don't care about that press
conference anyway game two they're gonna
be talking more that's
they're gonna be doing more fingers and
doing more antiques they
they don't care about that in boston so
they don't care why should you care just
play and win games like you said it's
just basketball i don't want to hear all
that right yeah i'm mad i don't want to
hear all that either man fans
listen mo i've always said this 95 of
the fans are amazing five percent you
could take them out back and i'd beat
the hell out of him
i've said that for 30 years but that's
only five percent most of the fans agree
but
i don't want to talk about this crap
he's talking about that was just one of
the best basketball games i've seen in a
long time
you know kenneth touched on it earlier
that was everybody on that court could
sleep good tonight
because everybody competed competed
competed and we'll talk about his
silliness fans gonna say some things
and listen it's the nature of the beast
that's the nature of the beast